manchmal muss man einfach genießen sei
es auch nur aus der ferne thailand von
seiner schönsten seite und nahezu
menschenleer
kein tourismus in corona zeiten
das heißt auch die einheimischen haben
ihr paradies exklusiv zutaten sieht der
sonne beim aufgehen zu raus aufs meer
geht der blick das ist seine welt
mir gefällt das leben auf dem wasser vom
boot aus hast du immer alle richtungen
du siehst den sonnenaufgang und den
sonnenuntergang und die insel die wolken
das alles sind noch schöner aus von
meinem haus aus kann ich nur den
sonnenaufgang sehen als stehe die zeit
still zu leben die mocken thailand see
nomaden leben in ihrer eigenen
geschwindigkeit aber trotzdem nicht fern
von dem was auch den rest der welt
beschäftigt und besorgt wegen corona
habe ich mit meiner familie zwei monate
nur auf dem boot gelegt da waren wir
sicher da gibt es kein corona und es war
ganz ruhig ohne touristen
das ist sonst anders inseln wie koh yao
akoya neue coupé musik in den ohren der
internationalen reisebranche
kein wunder in einem thailand dessen
regeln der tourismus definiert dass
hotels brauchte stadt fischerdörfer
mussten die mocken sehen wo sie bleiben
zitate lebt hier seit 40 jahren sein
leben lang einer von wenigen tausend
moog in ein nischen dasein aus der zeit
gefallen so fischen wir mit dem speer
das ist unsere tradition aber es ist
nicht leicht
manchmal klappt es manchmal nicht denn
die fische sind schnell und schwimmen
zickzack zutaten ist ein könner
bei der jagd ist er auf sich allein
gestellt aber plötzlich und unerwartet
gibt es da einen ungewöhnlichen
verbündeten corona durch corona geht es
der natur besser weniger tote weniger
touristen und auch weniger müll
sonst war hier viel mehr überall
für mich ist die jagd jetzt einfacher
früher habe ich stundenlang nach fischen
gesucht sagt corona gibt es wieder mehr
unter wasser ist das leben in den
vergangenen monaten sichtbar aufgeblüht
korallen erholen sich fische vermehren
sich und tiere die man ewig nicht
gesehen hat tauchen wieder auf das
paradies kehrt zurück auch in die maria
b das ist hollywood the beach wo
leonardo dicaprio sein film abenteuer
bestritt mit konsequenzen aus der
einzelnen bucht wurde ein hotspot 5000
besucher tag für tag boote über boote
schaulust ohne gnade für das gefühl auch
mal da gewesen zu sein
tourismus pervers korallen zertrampelt
tiere verscheucht wasser verdreckt
schon vor corona wuchs die einsicht das
geht so nicht weiter
seither fährt der ranger saisonturnier
streife seither ist maria beach nur aus
der distanz zu sehen betreten ist
verboten
wir sorgen dafür dass keine boote mit
touristen an den strand fahren dass
keine fischer kommen
das ist jetzt alles illegal die erholung
der bucht ist sichtbar und messbar
sie nehmen wasserproben auf qualität und
temperatur mit dem thermometer messen
wir in verschiedenen tiefen drei meter
fünf meter und zu verschiedenen
tageszeiten die wassertemperatur ist
wichtig wenn es zu warm ist vergleichen
die korallen und sterben ab die probleme
der natur waren und sind komplex aber
die hauptursache ist identifiziert teil
als renommiertester meeresbiologe
benennt sie zweifelsfrei vor corona
kamen jedes jahr 40 millionen touristen
nach thailand 33 millionen davon haben
badeurlaub am meer gemacht und mit einem
mal sind die alle verschwunden
so sind auch die ganzen boote weg keine
beachpartys mehr kein lärm aus den
hotels kommt weniger abwasser weniger
müll was für ein unterschied
die touristen sind thailand wichtigste
einnahmequelle
dass der reisestopp schlecht fürs
geschäft ist eine maßlose untertreibung
die gähnende leere an den stränden ist
eine wirtschaftliche katastrophe für
sehr viele menschen und sogar
umweltschützer sagen der tourismus müsse
wieder anlauf ohne tourismus ohne die
sehnsucht nach kreisen wunderschönen
urlaubszielen hätten die menschen nie
begriffen dass sie die natur bewahren
müssen das wäre ihnen egal ob korallen
sterben der ans meer fährt der sieht die
schönheit der will sich schützen
wir können nicht auf null tourismus aber
den wahnsinn ja vor kroner hersteller
den stoppen
sanfter tourismus umweltverträglicher
regulierter das soll die zukunft sein
ab juli will phuket geimpfte urlauber
wieder einreisen lassen dann zeigt sich
wie ökonomie und ökologie sich vertragen
auch so tat als leben kommt dann wieder
in ein anderes fahrwasser
er wird sein paradies wieder teilen
müssen doch was er nicht ändern kann
bringt ihn nicht aus der ruhe
ich mache mir gar nicht viele gedanken
um die zukunft
ich lebe in diesem augenblick ich fahre
rausgefischt zum überleben
das ist schon alles was zählt sein leben
ist einfach könnte man sagen oder
sein leben ist einfach schön vom boot
aus betrachtet jedenfalls hat er alles
was er will
sonnenuntergang inklusive